[Musik]
jedes jahr beginnen mehr als
hunderttausend menschen ein neues leben
in der schweiz aus verschiedenen
kulturen und sozialen schichten hoffen
sie alle dass die schweiz ihr neues
zuhause wert
doch nicht alle bleiben jedes jahr
kehren auch mehrere zehntausend menschen
wieder zurück in ihre alte heimat
dies ist die geschichte von vier
familien die wir in den letzten jahren
bei ihrer einwanderung in die schweiz
begleitet haben
was ist aus ihnen geworden sind sie
geblieben und haben sie ihr glück
gefunden
[Musik]
asis abdulkarim mit seiner familie
gekommen um dem krieg in syrien zu
entfliehen
sommer 2014 über die türkei schaffen sie
es bis in die schweiz
sie suchen sicherheit und erhalten asyl
ein neues leben beginnt
an diesen beiden orten bekommen sie
informationen wie sie ihre diplome
anerkennen lassen können doch das ist
schwierig der ehemalige chefarzt muss
wieder ganz von vorne anfangen mein
leben in der schweiz ist ein einziges
warten warten
[Musik]
makaay der schotte aus deutschland seien
neuanfang in diesem tisch die alte
heimat war ihm zu eng geworden
[Musik]
der englischlehrer will in graubünden
ein neues kapitel aufschlagen
[Musik]
der plan
jan will zunächst mit den beiden
töchtern vorausgehen
seine frau marion und der sohn sollen
ein jahr später nachkommen
doch die trennung tut weh
auch mit der integration im dorf hartes
und so platzt der traum vom neuen leben
nach wenigen monaten
wir wollten ein bisschen zu viel
die meisten hatten wir ein tolles leben
wir dachten hier könnten wir es noch
besser haben
das war unser größter fehler lisa die
portugiesin auf der suche nach einkommen
und liebe
mit der arbeit hat es problemlos
geklappt
lisa kam 2014 in die schweiz
seither arbeitet sie in einem alters-
und pflegeheim
dabei hilft es ihr dass sie bereits
fließend deutsch spricht
hallo da bin ich wieder
dieser ist integriert doch wenn immer
möglich preist sich zurück nach portugal
besuchen ihre beiden söhne und ihre alte
mutter lisa ist geschieden und muss ihre
studierenden söhne von der schweiz aus
finanziell unterstützen
dort fühlt sie sich oft einsam ich meine
tage und momente die sie zu schwierig
genug scheiße allein sei es nicht
einfach besonders in einem fremden land
[Musik]
drachenboot war und nagoya die manager
aus indien beide kommen aus der
hauptstadt deal
[Musik]
ein geordnetes leben zusammen mit der
tochter dia und den eltern von raúl
nachdem er ein jobangebot als ceo einer
schweizer firma erhalten hat beginnt für
sie in der schweiz ein alltag ohne
hausangestellte wie sehr hat der raúl
für alles bedienstete
in der schweiz muss er sich alleine
durchschlagen um die ankunft seiner frau
und tochter vorzubereiten
alltägliche dinge wie einkaufen sind für
ihn neuland
man ist das schwer ich brauche eine
pause welche keinen wagen nehmen sollen
der inder schlägt sich durch so gut er
kann weiß wohnen in der schweiz warten
sich die beiden zum ersten mal in ihrem
leben gemeinsam ans abenteuer selber
kochen
das ist gar nicht so kompliziert
indisches essen sieht kompliziert aus
aber eigentlich ist das wirklich einfach
ich glaube wir sind hier organisierter
und respektvoller geworden zum beispiel
spüren wir jetzt unsere eigenen
kaffeetassen bei der arbeit
drei jahre ist es her dass die familie
in die schweiz kam in indien war die
shopping-mall wochenendausflugs ziel in
der schweiz geht es raus in die natur
siehst du das am baum wird welche frucht
ist dass ich weiß es nicht
kann man das essen auf dem pfannkuchen
daran erinnerst du dich ich denke das
ist dieselbe vor
das ist schön ich mache mal ein foto die
inder genießen die schweiz
wir kommen jeden tag aus dem haus und
denken was für ein perfektes land ich
meine die infrastruktur die natur die
sauberkeit
es ist einfach immer schön sobald man
vor die tür geht
wir haben alle familien gebeten sich
episoden aus der vergangenheit
anzuschauen
die welt der gut was vor vier jahren
ich frühstücke mal
mega dorian wird von ihr chauffeur zur
arbeit gefahren
tja s bänden ich verbringe jeden tag
zwei bis drei stunden im auto was für
eine verschwendung von zeit
das mag ich hier in indien überhaupt
nicht fester bestandteil des lebens in
indien familien events die zeremonie zur
einweihung eines neuen appartements wenn
ich das sehe vermisse ich meine familie
damals hatte ich angst zu gehen
unser ganzes leben war super eingespielt
und plötzlich macht der mann karriere
und man muss aus der komfortzone heraus
in ein land wo man niemanden kennt wo
alles neu ist weit weg von der familie
das hat mir angst gemacht ich musste
meinen job aufgeben das war ein totaler
programm netzel
aber ich denke ich habe es gut
hingekriegt
inzwischen machen sie es wie die
schweizer nach der wanderung wird
eingekehrt
[Musik]
auch wenn es manchmal hapert die
deutsche sprache ist teil ihres lebens
geworden
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
seht ihr die werbung da wo die dame
steht das sind zwei leckere ice camps
drauf als ich mir das näher angeschaut
habe habe ich gesehen dass da hunde
klasse geschrieben steht
eiscreme für hunde das sieht super
lecker aus wirklich möchte
das ist sicher lecker in der schweiz
verbringt er wohl wesentlich mehr zeit
mit seiner tochter als in indien
nur land
glücklichsein hängt letztlich nicht von
besonderen sachen ab es sind die kleinen
freuden wie diese hier
[Musik]
aber schnell so in etwa sah es aus als
der syrer abdul karim das erste mal die
schweiz erblickte vier jahre später ist
das alltag die fahrstrecke zur arbeit
ich arbeite als assistenzarzt in der
abteilung für innere medizin
da gibt es eine notaufnahme und eine
normale station
das ist jetzt fast dasselbe was sich
auch in syrien gemacht habe in syrien
war asis ein angesehener chefarzt heute
arbeitet er als assistenzarzt in einem
regionalspital im kanton waadt
immerhin denn lange war nicht klar ob
der syrische flüchtlinge in der schweiz
seinen job und sein ansehen
zurückbekommen würde asylgesuch
anerkannt aufenthaltsbewilligung b das
war vor fünf jahren noch ganz anders
auch aziz und seine familie blickten
zurück
es ist auf dem weg zu einem
vorstellungsgespräch im unispital genf
mit großen hoffnungen
der syrische arzt hofft einen großen
schritt in richtung neues leben machen
zu können
wenn ich richtig verstanden habe möchten
sie bei uns in der poliklinik ein
praktikum absolvieren
zu sehen wie unser medizin funktioniert
genau das ist das eine und dann möchte
ich mein studium vervollständigen und
hier als arzt arbeiten
ich dachte das gespräch sei gut
verlaufen
das war aber nicht so das budget ich
habe das falsch verstanden
dieses komplizierte prozedere das war
wirklich schwierig für mich
am besten wäre wenn sie hier wie ein
student beginnen und mit den anderen
ärzten mit laufen würden
[Musik]
das war ein schock für mich als ob all
meine studien nichts wert wären
syrien geflüchtet sind dachte ich in der
schweiz
ich habe bereits eine spezialisierung da
werde ich sicher eine arbeit finden weil
ich ja bereits ein facharzt in dem war
nicht so es fängt wieder ganz unten an
immerhin eineinhalb jahre nach dem
gespräch arbeitet er wieder in einem
spital
[Applaus]
die portugiesin lisa hat es vom strand
portugals nach bilanz graubünden
verschlagen
die arbeit läuft doch wie sah vermisst
ihr familien und sozialleben der alten
heimat
abwechslung bringen ihr vor allem die
shoppingtouren dieselben läden immer
wieder
ich werde immer die mode maus sein und
das ist für mich wichtig dass es
irgendwie filmen ihn bleibt und jetzt
gehe ich zum beispiel die leben draußen
leute wissen schon nicht kaufen nichts
aber ich gehe einfach rein wollte weil
ich einfach so ein einkaufsbummel gerne
mache und die paletten die es gibt und
das ist ganz schnell die leute kennen
mich schon habe ich jetzt auch eine
woche am strand gehe weiß es ist noch
gemütlich finde am abend dass ich jetzt
meine ecke geworden und das heißt wenn
ich jetzt nach portugal fliegen und
wieder zurückkomme
ich freue mich auf meine ecke und das
ist mein platz und da sind meine sachen
und das ist ja das ist halt wieder zu
hause
auch lisa blick zurück in ihr altes
leben
[Musik]
im norden portugals unterstützt sie ihre
beiden arbeitslosen söhne so gut es geht
mit geld aus der schweiz und mit
zuspruch
darüber hinaus muss sie für ihre kranke
mutter eine pflege organisieren
das alles kostet geld und dieses geld
muss sie in der schweiz erwirtschaften
für mich dürfen sie auch das was ich
schon immer geplant hatte meinen kindern
geben können dass sie sich ausbilden und
was fürs leben haben
das wollte ich auch weiterhin können
machen können und dass das hat mir dann
langsam habe ich dann gemerkt in
portugal das werde ich die krise war
immer stärker besonders in meinem in
meinem bereichen textil die immer
stärker und ich habe mich da finanziell
nicht durchsetzen können und das waren
zwei große jungen und es eine wohnung
das war ziemlich viel
die letzten jahre eine zeit der
entbehrungen aber auch eine zeit in der
lisa sich einen traum erfüllen konnte
zumal mein auto tiptop aber ich habe das
auto immer noch es ist gut es
funktioniert dass mein ganzes leben lang
auch wo ich verheiratet war hat das
immer mein mann gemacht so etwas
mitgemacht was mache ich jetzt ganz für
mich mit meinem geld als er weiß noch
extrem emotional was man für sich selbst
so viel geld braucht das verstehe ich
gar nicht ich habe gedacht das hat man
nur mit kindern
also ich war jetzt muss dann bei der
bank nach arbeitsschluss 5000 franken
für das traumauto vom munde abgespart
3000 kann sie in bar auf den tisch legen
der rest folgt in kleinen raten danke
vielmals ich wusste dass ich wirklich
ein auto haben und mir auch überhaupt
das gefühl geben
es ist eine neue phase und eine bessere
und nicht eine neue phase und eine
schlechtere meisten die alte neue heimat
von ihren makaay und seiner familie
iran ist jetzt seit zwei jahren zurück
aus der schweiz
hier im osten deutschlands fühlt sich
der schotte so wie er sich fühlen möchte
zu hause sehr gut ganz toll gute kontakt
mit den kollegen alles läuft prima ist
im moment wirklich super die schweiz
nimmt er mit in den unterricht
wie sind die schweizer als menschen
was ist euer bild eines typischen
schweizer reiche menschen schöne
landschaft schokolade
sie kennen sich alle untereinander
sie leben in kleinen dörfern meine tante
lebt in so einem dorf immer wenn wir
einen spaziergang machten grüßt sie alle
die ihr entgegenkommen seinen
gescheiterten gang in die schweiz macht
ihren kein geheimnis das war ein
interessantes jahr
aber nun bin ich wieder zurück es hat
nicht funktioniert alle wesen beton
nicht weil die schweizer nicht nett
wären deshalb weil einige dinge einfach
nicht so liefen wie geplant wird es
interessant dass ihr von kleinen dörfern
redet davon wo jeder jeden kennt und wo
man sich noch grüßt
da kann es schwierig sein reinzukommen
das ist wie eine eingeschworene
gemeinschaft wenn man von außen dazu
kommt ist das nicht einfach
meißen vor fünf jahren die welt die er
mit seiner familie damals hinter sich
lassen wollte
meistens schön platz fünf jahre geworden
hier aber jetzt ist das reife einfach
weiter machen musik musik
[Musik]
der umzug ins neue leben
alle müssen noch ein letztes mal die
ärmel hochkrempeln und mit anpacken
da sich die familie vorübergehend
aufteilt geht nur ein teil der möbel mit
in die schweiz
treibende kraft hinter dem umzug war
übrigens der schotte
ich glaub du musst das raus ja du hast
dich ein bisschen gefühlt wie so ein
tiger im käfig nichts ändert sich mehr
und hat es die hoffnung dass du wieder
etwas bewirken und verändern kannst
zunächst scheint die rechnung aufzugehen
ein highlight der ersten tage die
schüler reise in die berge
[Musik]
ich bin ja en entdeckt die schönheit der
schweizer natur
[Musik]
schau dir diese kulisse an
es tut mir gut
thomas e oh wow traumhaft noch mal sechs
total okay okay wäre schön öfter zu
sehen
tobi stimmt habe ich erzählt die
nordirland sind wir jeden
donnerstagabend mit allen lehrern auf
ein paar drinks
ich habe euch mal per zufall an einem
freitag getroffen
ich habe nicht so viel und nicht oft
genug versucht kontakte kontakte
auszubauen
aber es war schwer wir waren mehr
fixiert auf kontakt zwischen uns auch
neu allein mit den mädels zu sein für
alles verantwortlich zu sein zu kochen
zu waschen so weiter auch mitlaufen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
der arbeitsort das in das reboot war in
der nähe von zürich
der ceo leitet eine schweizer firma mit
70 mitarbeitern
beruflich ist an gang in die schweiz ein
schritt nach oben und inzwischen hat
wohl gelernt dass man auch ohne
chauffeur und hausangestellte ganz gut
leben kann
besonders wenn man entsprechend
ausgerüstet ist
ich habe das hier von einem meiner
kollegen geschenkt bekommen
das sind offenbar ganz wichtige
schweizer wörter
das ist offenbar ein besonders
schwieriges wort opel bis g rot und
röter
raúl ist kein chef der sich im büro
versteckt er mischt sich gerne unter
seine schweizer mitarbeiter auch wenn er
dann ständig in gefahr ist deutsch reden
zu müssen
wir haben
gäste von ihren plätzen
ich habe meine tochter freien geburtstag
oder bringen gemacht gebracht selber
gekocht für die nächste zeit du musst zu
meinem haus kommen
ich mache nicht nur die rösti waren eine
entdeckung
ich nehme mal monikas beispiel wenn
ingenieure mit mir arbeitet und ich ihm
sage ich brauche jetzt das und das dann
lässt die person sofort alles stehen und
liegen um es augenblicklich zu machen
monika zum beispiel bis dann gerade am
telefon und sagt mehr staub ich habe
grade zu tun
anschließend macht sich natürlich an
gott das ist auch eine gute art
fokussierte vor sie arbeitet dass man
einen sowie im ernst ihnen sehen und
dann geht sein kann wie zwischen oder
unser miteinander kollegen und hause wie
sich das klima strukturiert und das
finden sich auch lehrer anlaufenden
fluss das skifahren hast du verpasst
hab' mich bitte hochziehen
lasst das war wohl du schiebst mich in
die falsche richtung
ohne dich geht das besser das kann ich
inzwischen so viel besser
das ist wirklich peinlich
[Musik]
dank heute ziehe ich die skier an und
fahre richtig schuss das skifahren ist
eine wundervolle sache
ich liebe es die berge runter fahren das
ist toll ich genieße das jedes mal wie
machen das inzwischen zusammen mit der
ganzen familie das macht uns allen spaß
[Musik]
dies ist in seinem element nach fünf
jahren in der schweiz ist der ehemalige
chefarzt auf syrien wieder halbwegs das
was er einmal war
er kann als assistenzarzt arbeiten sein
arzt diplom für die schweiz jedoch muss
er noch nachholen
es ist nur rechts links tut ihnen nichts
mehr und der mund können sie den öffnen
das geht am nachmittag schauen wir was
wir machen können wenn es ein abszess
ist werden wir operieren müssen aber so
weit sind wir noch nicht
mein kollege gibt ihnen bescheid sobald
wir mehr wissen okay ich komme nachher
wieder vorbei es wird vom team geschätzt
möchtest du ein paar diät kekse
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ihr macht eine menge fortschritte mit
dem französisch er ist ein wirklich
fröhlicher mensch er lacht viel
es ist wirklich angenehm mit ihm zu
arbeiten das stimmt er lacht eigentlich
meistens und er ist sehr diskret was
sein leben betrifft
ich hätte niemals gedacht dass er so
schlimme sachen erlebt hat bei der
arbeit lässt er das nie durchblicken
ais frau hat noch keine arbeit gefunden
die familie bekommt kaum noch
finanzielle unterstützung als lohn muss
für alle reichen
dennoch ist er zufrieden ich habe jetzt
ein normales leben
ich finde dass es gut ich habe mich
integriert ich bin wieder in der medizin
tätig all das tut mir wirklich gut
noch ein halbes jahr dann wird er seine
prüfung machen können du hast uns
wirklich gefehlt
ja ja richtig gefehlt
[Musik]
in meißen sind ihren und marion zusammen
mit freunden auf einem integrationsfest
für flüchtlinge seit ihren rückkehr nach
deutschland engagieren sie sich in
diesem bereich das fest wird organisiert
von der lokalen flüchtlingshilfe
deutsche und flüchtlinge bringen hier
gemeinsam garten zum blühen und marion
waren fast von anfang an mit dabei und
das ist genau als er zurückkam kamen die
die flüchtlinge 2015 markt ist für uns
was fast wie ein glück als plötzlich die
leute hier kam ihr aus syrien und irak
und iran und afghanistan
und wir haben auch richtig freuen
er ist glücklich umgeben von seiner
familie und freundin lebte den
gesellschaftlichen austausch den er in
der schweiz so sehr vermisst hat
[Musik]
mittwoch waschtag am ende
es gibt wichtige dinge im leben als haus
[Gelächter]
marion ist noch in deutschland ich habe
immer geholfen mit mit dem haushalt der
unterschied ist die die trennung
zwischen ich und meine frau dass die wir
sind nicht zusammen und das das tut weh
manchmal tut wirklich weh
[Musik]
die haben uns gar nicht gesehen gestern
stimmt hallo hallo
wie war euer tag wesentlich als kuchen
war super lecker was waren das für ein
kuchen stimmung damals reinspringen in
einem bergdorf schwer
geld ist nicht alles neben qualität muss
stimmen zu stellen und dann findet im
moment das geht nicht
kipp punkt erreicht ich habe immer
gewartet auf eine schöne aha moment ein
schöner jetzt ich bin hier zwar wissen
glücklich alles läuft toll und es ist
nie gekommen
also du wolltest du wolltest wirklich du
wolltest nacht nach dresden nach münchen
zurück und die lehrer das ist ja aber
halt nicht so perfekt für mich und ich
war glücklich dass ich wieder in einem
großen haus grund und auch mit meiner
mutter dass wir ja was teenager ist
glaub ich wichtig die mutterfigur zu
haben er hat ja dann ein jobangebot
angenommen in der international school
was finanziell eigentlich eine
katastrophe war für uns das muss man mal
ganz ehrlich sagen das war ein
rückschritt ja den den wir bis jetzt
nicht aufgeholt haben
und wenn ich nicht damals diese
lohnerhöhung gekriegt hätte dann weiß
ich nicht
dieser geht es nach vier jahren in der
schweiz finanziell besser als früher
[Musik]
ich suche jetzt zb einfach so einen
stockfisch viele für das was ich machen
will
ich sehne mich nach diesen typischen
essen ich erinnere mich sogar noch an
meinen eltern gehen in deutschland waren
war das auch so
die wir müssten auch immer einmal in der
woche zum portugiesischen laden weil da
gab es einfach so der geschmack und das
was sagen was man sich gewohnt das was
man gerne bei uns ist
[Musik]
früher in portugal hat sie selten nur
für sich gekocht in der schweiz ist sie
auch nach vier jahren noch meistens
alleine
ja das erinnert mich an bord war wo ich
dann für die ganze familie gekocht habe
eigentlich mag es mir viel freude wenn
ich dass wir jemand kochen dürfte und
zeigen und geben zum essen
das wird das wird noch mehr freude
machen also für mich eigentlich hatte
dieser gehofft nach ihrer scheidung in
der schweiz auch eine neue liebe zu
finden
ein rückblick vor vier jahren dieser ist
in den bergen unterwegs und wie meistens
alleine
[Musik]
meine schön stiefel somit was soll ich
das jetzt putzen
da sieht man sofort ich bin nicht aus
dem land ihre hoffnungen mit einem neuen
partner in der schweiz ein leben
aufzubauen haben sich nicht verwirklicht
ich würde mich vieles verlieben in der
schweiz
aber irgendwie ist das jetzt so
das sticht auf besuch bin ja deshalb
habe ich viele stimmungsschwankungen
auch und ich versuche mich her
[Musik]
ein zu leben und das leben geht weiter
meine vorstellung sind immer noch da
die habe ich bis jetzt noch nicht
umsetzen können weder in portugal wo es
einfacher sein sollte dass mein name ist
und hier habe ich sie auch noch nicht
umsetzen können
[Musik]
natürlich habe ich männer kennengelernt
um mich verschiedene die halt nur
kollegen sind oder wo es halt auch mal
mehr interesse da war aber so gefunkt
hat es jetzt bei keinem also ist zahlt
noch oder was das da war das lasse ich
gerne so laufen
en und marion mangelt es nach der
rückkehr nach deutschland nicht an
kontakten
das haus das sie eigentlich für die
schweiz zurück lassen wollten ist zum
treffpunkt für alte und neue freunde
geworden
unter dem geflüchteten sind so für
unsere freunde geworden stellte und im
sommer haben wir gartenparty tränen
zusammen gegessen united nations hotel
bei uns bei dem begriff
[Musik]
im musikkeller probt derweil mit seinen
musikern für seinen auftritt vor den
freunden
seit seiner rückkehr vergeht kein tag an
dem er nicht unter freunden ist wo meine
frau ist um mein freundeskreis sitzt und
das ist meine heimat und ich habe das
gefunden
die rückkehr nach deutschland für seine
freunde kein scheitern
das kann ich gut nachvollziehen ich
selbst mal für ein jahr auf die andere
seite der usa gezogen und das hat auch
nicht funktioniert
du gibst dir mühe dich anzupassen und
das funktioniert einfach nicht
dann kommst du mit eingezogenem schwanz
zurück und stehst vor denen die du
zurück gelassen hast aber das ist okay
es gehört zu den lebenserfahrungen maske
siehst du besser aus fazit haben sie ihr
glück gefunden die uns also mir ist
bewusst geworden dass was eigentlich
vorher schon hatten
das müssen wir brauchten vielleicht
diesen umweg um zu realisieren was ja
gar keine große veränderung brauchen
die familie makaay ausgezogen um noch
mehr glück zu finden als sie bereits
hatten
[Musik]
zurückgekehrt um es dort zu finden wo
sie es zurückgelassen hatten
[Musik]
bei lisa geht es wesentlich ruhiger zu
ein arbeitsfreier tag abstand vom alters
und pflegeheim
dieser versteht es ihrem alltag immer
wieder positive seiten abzugewinnen
wunderbar da ist richtig schön viel
fisch drin
geschmack ist schon portugal aber die
das ganze ambiente das ist natürlich was
ganz anderes da ist man schon lieber in
port weil aber hierzu auch besuch von
der familie ist selten und ein highlight
die damals vor vier jahren
[Musik]
visa erwartet ihren sohn etwa er möchte
das neue leben seiner mutter
kennenlernen
[Musik]
bist du angekommen mein lieber eine
halbe stunde eher spät war es denn
[Musik]
schön hast du es hier auf den fotos sah
das nicht so schön aus wenn du ein
kissen haben möchtest nimmt doch das
hier
ich bin stolz auf das was ich erreicht
habe und es freut mich dass sich die bei
mir habe und die das miterleben einfach
dieser möchte ihrem sohn etwas bieten
sie nimmt ihn mit auf die ski pisten
schnee hat er noch nie gesehen gar nicht
so einfach
ich sinke 1 ich denke sie hat die
richtige entscheidung getroffen
ich weiß es ist oft hart für sie ich
möchte sie moralisch unterstützen und
von meiner seite in portugal alles so
machen dass sie sich um uns keine sorgen
machen muss und hier ihr leben leben
kann
irgendwie sind lisa söhne immer mit
dabei auch wenn sie nicht da sind
[Musik]
das schicke man den söhnen damit sie
schön der makro wird ganz glücklich dann
weiß er ich mache jetzt portugiesisches
essen das er ist einfach dafür dass ich
so viel macht wie möglich damit ich
nicht so viel sehnsucht habe trotz
sehnsucht und einsamkeit nach vier
jahren ihr fazit wenn ich zurückdenke
ich hätte es wieder gemacht wie eine
ähnlichkeit
ich finde alles was ich erlebt habe und
alles was ich durchgemacht habe war es
wert weil ich bin ich bin so gewachsen
ich habe nicht nur zugenommen ich bin
noch gewachsen ich bin so gewachsen dass
ich das ist das sind eigentlich das was
uns großmacht im leben sind dieser
dieser lebenserfahrung und ich hätte
diese lebenserfahrung port gar nicht
gemacht
das heißt du besitzen mit möglich ja ich
bin ich wunschlos glücklich aber ich bin
zufrieden
[Musik]
in lausanne haben aziz und seine familie
vor allem eins gewonnen sicherheit auch
aziz frau sarah hat französisch gelernt
auch sie möchte gerne arbeit geben doch
bisher ist es mit der arbeitssuche
schwierig wenn er sie es arbeitet bin
ich mit den kindern alleine da ist es
schwierig nach einer arbeit zu suchen
oder mich um etwas anderes als die
kinder zu kümmern
zu hause wird vor allem kurdisch
gesprochen
auch wenn beide die sprache ihrer neuen
heimat sehr schnell erlernt haben noch
einmal der blick zurück auf damals ein
jahr nach ihrer ankunft asis und seine
familie haben asyl erhalten
die schweiz bietet ihnen die erhoffte
sicherheit
jetzt haben sie neue ziele als erstes
französisch lernen
tag für tag
ich versuche die zeit formen zu erkennen
perfekt imperfekt präsenzkultur und so
weiter im französischen gibt es so viele
zeitformen fünf jahre nach seiner
ankunft zieht auch der ambitionierte
arzt seine persönliche bilanz wir haben
nur ein einziges leben
wir haben eine menge zeit verloren
wirklich wirklich stellen sie sich vor
wenn sie auf einen schlag fünf jahre
ihres lebens verlieren wurde vielleicht
sogar noch mehr einfach so
aber für die kinder ist es besser hier
als gärtner in syrien wird die lage
immer schlimmer
der ampera
[Musik]
ich hoffe dass es sich dennoch zum
besseren wendet denn ganz ehrlich was
eines tages möchte ich zurück nach
syrien
das ist mein ziel eines tages zurück zu
gehen nach syrien
auch wenn ich nicht weiß wann das sein
wird für die kinder ist die schweiz die
einzige welt die sie kennen
hier wachsen sie auf und hier gehen sie
zur schule syrien können sie durch ihre
eltern und aus dem fernsehen
fünf jahre nach der flucht vor dem krieg
haben die abtun karims ein leben in der
schweiz
was sie als heimat definieren werden
eltern und kinder sicher in zukunft
diskutieren müssen
[Musik]
das dritte jahr in der schweiz an die
hausarbeit haben sich mega und raúl
inzwischen gewöhnt
so ist das leben während die einen hart
arbeiten genießen die anderen ihr leben
ich habe die ja fertig gemacht zur
schule gebracht und wieder abgeholt das
sind sicher zwei drei stunden arbeit
ich denke wenn wir die stunden zählen
habe ich locker mehr gemacht hast du
wirklich darüber werden wir wohl noch
öfter diskutieren
mit 30 lernen jetzt endlich wie es ist
für uns selbst zu sorgen
niemand der einem das essen serviert und
die kleidung wäscht sich auch nicht mehr
von alleine und ist auf magische weise
immer zum tragen bereit für schweizer
verhältnisse kommt dass sich ein wenig
spät aber immerhin wir machen schweizer
im alltag in der im herzen ganz ehrlich
manchmal vermisse ich die familie bin
ich einfach zu viel um die ohren haben
dann vermisse ich was wir in indien
hatten
manchmal vermisse ich die wärme der
großfamilie
[Musik]
oder wenn wir mal ausgehen wollen und
einen babysitter brauchen
das sind so die momente in denen wir
unser altes zuhause vermissen auch an
die beiden inder die frage war es das
wert
ich denke das ist es absolut wert
abgesehen vom beruflichen ist es vor
allem sich mit anderen menschen kulturen
und lebensarten auseinanderzusetzen wenn
man reist und neue menschen trifft wird
man ein offener mensch
man wird offener und das mensch reif ich
würde es sofort wieder keine frage
als ich in indien war hatte ich eine
eher traditionelle sicht auf das leben
heiraten karriere kinderkriegen ein
normales leben führen
ich war viel weniger offen für neues
jetzt nachdem ich hier in die schweiz
gekommen bin bin ich eher bereit auch
mal ein risiko einzugehen
ich bin hier merke ich dass wir nur ein
leben haben und es wirklich leben müssen
ich denke in dieser hinsicht habe ich
mich verändert
ich traue mich eher dinge auszuprobieren
glücklich zu leben anstatt nur auf die
karriere zu achten
heute gibt es mehr andere dinge die mein
leben inspirieren
die beste kleidung das beste auto das
beste restaurant das alles hat für uns
nicht mehr so viel bedeutung bei der
zeit zusammen zu verbringen das ist
wirklich wichtig so kauf nicht ständig
neue klamotten
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
der sucher kochen